hello everyone my name is taha kashut
i'm director of machine learning and
chief
medical officer at amazon web services
really glad to be here with you today
and sorry we couldn't couldn't be
in person due to the govit pandemic
today i'll be discussing the role of
artificial intelligence
and transforming healthcare a topic that
i'm really
excited about for a number of reasons
first of all
artificial intelligence is not not a new
concept
in its application in medicine uh dates
all the way back
to early 1960s with the eliza
conversational
psycho
diagnostic between a patient and their
physician
about how it can go through a decision
tree to be able to find
uh the various differential diagnoses um
for a patient um or later in the 1970s
when
artificial intelligence application of a
set of algorithms were able to
be compared to infectious disease docs
that trying to identify sepsis within
within a hospital and if you look at the
last
three years it's really amazing to see
over a hundred thousand
pubmed publications have in uh the topic
of artificial
artificial intelligence almost half of
those talk about
deep learning and various ways about how
machine learning and its applications
surfacing in artificial intelligence
applications
throughout administrative throughout
operational as well as clinical
differentiating diagnosis and and and
treatments and drug discovery
so uh and you probably have seen these
technologies described in a number of
various ways across industry uh whether
it's financial in
in environment and and manufacturing
and if anything you know amazon is the
greatest example about this
um the if you receive the shipment to
your home um
most likely you have um experience
artificial intelligence
um and then with the adoption of cloud
computing this is cloud was invented by
amazon
um you can realize that how the
competition power
needed for distributing these algorithms
at scale and accuracy is something that
really can can bring this
to to many many applications um uh
within uh within the palm of our hands
or within our
realm in various um
applications that require human
intelligence
almost always this is related to some
kind of complex decision-making where
human judgment would be required
most use cases for ai are looking for
probabilistic
outcome for example can you make a
prediction or a decision with high
degree of certainty similar to human
judgment
most also ai systems today created using
machine learning
which uses large amount of high quality
data
to create and validate decision logic uh
known as model
and then the ai application then feeds
input
data into that model and then that model
outputs human-like
decisions so machine learning is is sort
of the under
underlying technology or engine that is
powering this intelligent
uh system and while deep learning is one
type of machine learning of course there
are
many other techniques uh there but it's
the highest quality
sort of um approach that
um that known as deep neural network
um similar how the brain functions and
how the
the networks are interconnected this
lets ai systems really address more
complex use cases that was uh previously
than that was previously possible one of
the greatest things about artificial
intelligence
is various applications where
we believe the dust has settled on
things such as natural language
understanding and processing
such as pattern recognition
of various applications as i'll talk
to you about and as well as prediction
and and um and forecasting based on
prior knowledge or
a priority uh experiences that we
we have we have um the reach of machine
learning is is growing
um from being aspirational technology to
really mainstream
um uh um
applications incredibly fast uh pace and
and and many with outcomes that you can
actually measure and benchmark
against for a long time technology was
limited to a few major tech companies or
academic institutions and where you
needed
a ton of expertise and and knowledge to
be able to kind of use these tools or
develop in in these tools
but things began to change with as i
mentioned cloud computing
um enter the mainstream where um and
vast amount of
compute and data acquired have become
more readily available and affordable
quite literally machine learning is now
making impact across
finance retail fashion real estate
and many many applications in healthcare
as as we see
in our today is especially with our
customers in amazon web services the
altachon
throughout the talk today um it's moving
also from
being proprietary in to being core part
of every business
and industry uh democratize where we can
see many applications at edge
and and global applications uh which is
something that uh today we
we dearly need in healthcare um
uh if anything to close the gaps in in
healthcare
if you look at the world population
today almost 50 percent of world
population
does not have access um to any kind of
care
uh not just high quality care and this
is really where machine learning can can
can help bridge a lot of these gaps
whether through telemedicine whether
through uh accurate predictions
and and and forecasting and as well as
provide many many tools to to connect
the dots
with um with many of these patients
where you can aid doctors and physicians
to really scale to cover more population
especially with
repetitive tasks such as screening
and and routine
sort of medical tasks um
let me start what we hear quite a bit
from our customers
as today with a number of challenges
specific to healthcare which is
sort of the topic of today the great
thing as i mentioned
about you know artificial intelligence
is
the more accurate algorithms such as
deep learning
the cloud computing that can really help
us
scale and and um and provide the uh
the necessary infrastructure to um to
operate
uh these algorithms but um but there's
also
um different kind of shifts in in
healthcare that was
going to aid more and more of data
sharing uh
there's more outcome based so the
value-based care that's required to
make decision decisions so the
healthcare is moving from pay for
procedures to pay for performance and
outcome
so that way where you can as you treat
patients you
also pay attention to prevention as well
as what is the right
um sort of approach as a team of
healthcare providers be able to take
care of an individual
and to end uh so that requires
many data points about the individual
longitudinally
presented in a way that you can start
finding sometimes needles in a haystack
and often time is
connecting the dots in a patient journey
towards really making the right
assumptions about this individual
and what is the right treatment path for
them and then be able then to measure
how the different interventions or
treatments or
preventions are really helping this
individual
which ultimately what we're trying to
kind of get to the known as
the precision medicine how can i treat
an individual
for um for everything about them the
environment
that they sit in but also everything we
know about them from
not just the medical history but also
from the social economic
data as well as as
genetic information family history and
everything and how we can really can
uh the constellation of all these can be
put together so value-based care as it
stands
um which is requires
quite a bit of data driven decision
making but we don't have the necessary
resources to implement is what we hear
often from
customers um uh when i talk to
uh colleagues of mine physicians i mean
a burnout is
is uh oh and it's a big part of it is
of of healthcare um in the front lines
is
a lot of manual processes they have to
go to even with digital systems like
electronic medical records they need to
input those
data find the finding and retrieval
information is just as
as a repetitive task and oftentimes it's
a daunting task i mean imagine that you
have a patient that you're taking care
of have been through
so many different procedures throughout
their um
journey across many many institutions i
mean literally looking through
sifting through harry potter worth of
documentation that you need to kind of
um
extract the right level of meaningful
information from that to be able to kind
of care for them and
and and help them if you look at the
um the i.t systems that power most of
the healthcare infrastructure today
these are traditionally uh lack agility
in how they're built and how they scale
and customers want to keep a pace with
the technology then
that can really improve uh patient
outcome in the end
um also um a topic on everyone's mind in
healthcare is insufficient security and
compliance and availability that can
really hamper their ability to compete
and open the door to sophisticated and
hard
to identify attacks and lastly our
customers are expecting different kind
of experience
and the same thing with patients and
similar to consumer experience they they
would like
patients would love to engage with their
health more but similarly um
you know health care systems they want
to change that experience the level of
that they're
engaging more with their patient uh by
knowing more about
their journey and as well as as how they
can
they can help so um
how machine learning can help with a
variety of ways
where we're seeing machine learning is
being incorporated
in in healthcare from driving trends and
findings uh and insights uh for example
from
um what constitutes the large amount of
healthcare data today the unstructured
data
that's voice uh videos um
images of x-rays and and and mris uh
as well as as large amount of uh
narratives that's been documented in
various ways within these
healthcare systems um all the way to
focus on
differentiated value add by automating
expensive routine and manual processes
as well as building innovative new
products
uh this is really where um we believe
health you know machine learning can
help solve some of these challenges
if we have to pick on a few of these
areas for example care quality
improvement
uh this is one of the important ways to
improve patient care is by understanding
and analyzing
information trapped within their record
and then identifying the relationship
between these as
as the disease progress or as the
patient sort of
um treatment pathway
changes over time um and these come
oftentimes as i mentioned in narrative
forms these are like unstructured
medical texts
like hospital admission notes uh patient
medical history
as well as um many of uh different
um uh formats and different strong
different systems
uh like someone's electronic um uh
medical record um versus
where you have your ekg for the heart
scan or the eeg for the brain scan and
and video visits and transcri
transcriptions of dictations of
doctors notes and and
and so on so by pairing uh individual
health with predictive analytics machine
learning
can really um uh improve a patient lives
and personalize the care experience
where we're seeing a lot of applications
here is a
reduction of readmission to hospitals
after a
patient has gone through their procedure
or their visits
clinical utilization and how we can help
people live
better lives possible
uh if i give concrete examples um last
year we work with
harvard with israel deaconess medical
center um
on using deep learning models to
optimize uh schedule for 41
operating room and they were able to
align those schedules to improve
patient flow and in a patient setting
where they used a product that i'll
touch on today that understand the
context in medical narratives
called amazon company medical they were
able to extract
key medical terms and insights that they
used
to model in their machine learning
models to identify history and physical
key findings for each patient and in the
end operation
we end up saving 30 um
of their operation efficiency um uh
which is the next topic uh
um on um on here where machine learning
uh adoption in healthcare industry
we're seeing the application of that for
lots of documents and data
you know you look at prescription claims
medical forms images
maintaining up-to-date medical records
has become really a complicated process
about machine learning is simplifying
many of these
using document classification national
language understanding
such as text extraction speech to text
technologies
and medical comprehension capabilities
so you can understand the full
um context about an individual about
their history
um so this is helping mri is also like
the care infrastructure that is reducing
operation overhead
if you look at cambia health in the
north west
um building solutions that automatically
extract information from medication
medical conditions and treatments or
procedures
and then document them in a single
user-friendly platform
that cuts across many of the
underpinning systems that where the data
is being collected uh and then making
sense of it on
one longitudinal view uk uh
uk united kingdom's nhs business service
authorities also
improving customer experience and by
reducing the wait time
using natural language understanding in
their call centers
um often time in healthcare
there's a ton of data that needs to be
used for research
and there's a lot of back and forth
exchange of this information across
healthcare systems
that increase the the risk of
compromising
protected health information being
shared so this is another area where
a machine can do a really amazing job in
detecting these
phi data and then be able to on top of
that build the right model to mask or
reduct
this information before you share the
rest of the information about any
patient for whether it's for analytics
or for
patient uh care or outcome uh or
research
um and lastly uh one of the major areas
we're seeing a lot of our customers
early adopting machine learning is in a
patient population health analytics
so for example predicting health outcome
for a certain cohort
of of population this is the case with
cerner
healthy intent for example um
used um working with us on the
technologies we have in machine learning
on predicting heart failure risk of
heart failure for a patient
up to about 15 months in advance and
which gives you a ton of time
to be able to intervene and find the
right intervention that is needed
to get at that particular patient at
that particular point of time
revenue cycle management for example
automating claims processing
insurance claims or billing claims which
can be very manual process
today and and can take a very long time
and often time you end up missing a lot
of procedures and
and treatments that you should have
built for
where also machine learning can can help
with that
and most importantly also increasing
customer engagement and in this case uh
the patient as well as the caregivers
and
and um the healthcare providers uh where
um cha bots um or ambient
sort of experiences are really improving
the customer and consumer engagement
all the way from care from call center
solutions
or digital front doors for example
triage and patient server right
treatments which we see a lot today in
in covid
this can be ahead of a telemedicine
visit or could be ahead of actually
physical visit
so be able to kind of triage the the the
need and then be able to
uh to take that to the to the next level
all the way to
actually having the actual visit
especially at virtual visits
a big area as i mentioned earlier is
national language processing and
national language understanding and
healthcare is really ripe for this kind
of adopting machine learning
for to solve this problem today the vast
majority of healthcare data is
unstructured in nature
so if you want to build machine learning
that can really uh
try to kind of get at many of these use
cases as i mentioned
you need to have a lot of data in higher
higher quality and structured in a way
that you can really tap into
uh but when it's untreated when it when
it's
trapped into free text data physician
order data
nurse notes dictation notes um
this is where national language
processing can really help and
some of our customers as they face these
challenging challenges of dealing with
unstructured data
um uh we have uh been working on many
solutions to really
um help extract and structure this data
in a way that um adheres to the medical
terminology
uh so that we'll be able to kind of
adopt uh analytics
um whether and
machine learning algorithms on top um a
lot of healthcare
organizations have a huge amount in this
form of unstructured documents
so so and two things that are really
important here
first is extract the right key
information
from these various forms of how the data
is captured it's an image and audio
transcription or form
but also understand the context behind
it for example
you know if a patient had something in
their history
but that's something about the patient
history if the patient
stopped taking the medication and start
taking another medication
that context is is is very important
and often time local developed systems
uh they're really great
at extracting keywords but what they
miss is that context about how
these entities or keywords
are related to one another like for
example this adverse drug
event is related to this drug that was
started on this date and then in the
larger context it might be in
aggregation
might be seeing a pattern of this
behavior across
your subset of population that might be
at risk of
one condition or another condition down
the road so so so with that having the
right foundation
to not only extract that the data but
also understand how the data
interlinked with one another and the
knowledge graph behind that it becomes a
um quite a bit of a differentiating
heavy lifting for many
of these customers and and
uh by using national language
understanding or national language
processing with the underpinning of
machine learning
um you can start making sense of a lot
of data
that is clinically relevant um from
from this information so let's let's
double click on this a little bit about
some of the work that we're doing here
and what our customers are really
looking for
where machine learning can really great
can help automatically for example
detect and extract
text and data from scanned documents
better than
what you can do with optical character
recognition such as ocr
tools that many healthcare systems have
today
to also identify the content of fields
and and in each one of those forms
um oftentimes stored in tables and you
see that a lot also like for example in
laboratory
results and the meaning about every
value that
that might be extracted there uh machine
learning can also uh
help instantly read virtually just any
type of document and and extract the
data and
uh and and text with that the need for
any manual
human intervention other than be able to
provide the human in the loop
ways about how you can correct that
process if if the machine
having trouble understanding some of
these
text or there might be especially like
in laboratory um
tested if there's a new test on the
market is be able to also like have
different kind of custom codes uh
tailored to each individual where where
you can also
inject that in the flywheel of of the
learning
of this extraction you can also quickly
uh automate document workflows
um and enable process for example like a
million document
pages in less than an hour and then once
the information is captured then you can
take
action on it within your business
application so you can create smart
search indices
uh or build automated approval workflows
or this better decision support
um and then in aggregate then that
really can
not only maintain compliance with
document archival rules but also
start start really kind of contributing
to better
uh health care outcomes um for each
individual
that's been taken care of in the system
let's take an example for example here's
one form how would it look like
and then use a natural understanding and
and text extraction
you'll be you'll be able to extract
every key element within this form and
then
uh map value to that and then any
relation and then structure in a way
that can be fed
into a machine learning algorithm
for a variety of these uh use
cases uh medical audio is is is um
is a very common way about how
physicians document many of their
procedures and tests and in a way that
they can dictate and also uh we're
seeing more and more now
uh where there's especially around for
example like the telemedicine
applications
uh with coveted pandemic most of the
visits right now are done especially
ambulatory
care are done via telemedicine such as
video or or over the phone
and and then be able to kind of process
this
at scale and high accuracy and to be
able to structure this information in a
way that is mapped to medical ontology
is is is is very very
key to unlock insights from these these
kind of data
and also um oftentimes medical audio
this is when you're talking to for
example a patient talking to their
doctor
often time there's a lot of vernacular
terms being used
um such as for example you know it looks
like this drug ate a hole in my stomach
i mean
and the medical term for that is ulcer
or something similar to that and so you
need to be able to kind of
pay attention to those where the machine
is really great at um
at listening to those and be able to
kind of extract them in
in in their form to be able then to map
them to the right
medical ontology
so a lot of applications we see this
today
from medical speech text application
for example around clinical
documentation um physician dictation is
one one of those
drug safety center calls um and then
remote consultation with patients or
even payer and
provider contact centers and nurse
hotlines
we see a ton of these applications for
example in clinical
documentation voice scribes can be built
to capture both clinician patient
conversation
but even single speaker medical
dictation then be able to also
identify for example if you're looking
at an ambient experience
um who's the doctor who's the the doctor
aide
who's the patient and then be able to
kind of construct the right
level of summarization after that
from drug safety or we call
pharmacovigilance
phone calls from patients and
practitioners and um
for example poison hotlines and and
things about
drug adverse ev effects can actually be
transcribed from
a patient a patient conversation
and then build a pattern detection on
top of that
and as well as telemedicine and call
centers as i
um as i mentioned um what we're seeing
also with
many payers uh insurance companies for
example and healthcare providers
are also using trans uh transcription in
real time
to drive agent coaching and trigger
any downstream actions that needs to be
uh to be taken
in uh in real time uh images
is uh is is one of the most common
unstructured form of data
in healthcare so similarly machine
learning can really help detect
texts in these scan medical images and
then convert that detect image into a
machine readable text
in addition to be able to map what's in
the image and the pixels on the image
to the actual uh narrative from a
radiologist for example the physician
who's actually reading the image or
multiple
radiologists and then be able to kind of
compare those notes
uh across aggregate of the population to
be able to
not only extract the data and the
relationship but also understanding
the the variation that might happen and
ultimately be able to
train a different kind of models to be
able to pick up patterns
what is normal chess x-ray for example
or uh what is
a nodule and the location of that and is
this
subject to downstream um sort of actions
and
that sort of thing in order to make
sense of a lot of this information
so now uh now that we have all this
extracted data and
structure form all the relationships
that are
sort of built mapped to medical ontology
um
so so how do we make sense of it over
all and this is really where we start
getting into the understanding of this
um clinical data so you use a machine
learning we can
not only extract entities such as
disease condition
a medication the
dosage of of that medication the right
of that medication
when did they stop or start but you can
start kind of
tag every one of these information with
the right
trait as well as a relationship for
example between a medication's dosage
a test and its result or a condition an
adverse event
and then draw these relationships in
order to give
a sense or launching a view of
of that entire summary so that for each
individual patient
on a timeline so you'll be able to um uh
track the progression of an illness uh
for example and
and and the temporality that goes uh
goes
uh goes with it um also as i mentioned
earlier um
protected health information
identification is one of the key
application national language process
and that you can really do that the
highest accuracy today
with very little human intervention if
any
um with anthology then lincoln for
example so once you extract all these
medical
entities the relations uh the traits
around them
you can then start mapping them to the
right medical ontology this is common
nomenclature across
uh decades of of
how the data should be structured and
the right standards to follow
for example if you look at arcs norms
for medications or
drugs or icd 10 codes
for medical conditions you can start you
can start
generate accurate codes downstream for
processing that data for a number of
of use cases you can also uh with
machine learning
um overcome typos um
be able to summarize accurately
abbreviations or lack of structure
and um look at whether this is a genetic
name or a brand name
of a particular drug and then you'll be
able to kind of
have a really full sort of
representation of the data that's
accurately captured
in medical terms
if you look at similar with medical
conditions if you map those to
icd-10 for example you can now
start understanding comorbidities and
how that relates to the symptoms and
then be able to refine the
candidate concepts of that might be uh
related here and understand complex
contextual information to refine
also the um the candidate concept
or the latency and uh you know for
example the
the upper right lobe of the line that
means to understand the anatomy
understand the
um the the location um and
as well as the relationship to the
actual condition that you're you're
trying
to deal with here
temporality is is a really key
concept that national language
understanding can
help extract all these relationship
as i mentioned earlier the procedure
name
how that's linked for example whether
this is a
someone had the procedure in the past or
they got a procedure scheduled for them
in a future date uh what is the
diagnosis
um is this a current diagnosis or an
older diagnosis
and then figure out any overlaps that
you might find
in these
temporal sort of events that happen and
and suddenly what you what you end up
with
is a really rich um
corpus of information that is highly
structured
linked map to ontology that now you can
start
building a full complete picture for
every patient
once you have access to all the
information
so for example using temporality now you
can finally create a timeline
view of a patient from their certain
medication
over a period of time or procedures and
whatnot
and all mapped in front of you but also
when you look in
aggregation of the entire population
then you'll be able to start seeing some
patterns
and conditions and start really applying
pattern recognition algorithms or
forecasts in the prediction algorithms
to be able to kind of
further build cohort of this population
to be able to look at their
comorbidities be able to look at
their diagnosis or future sort of being
risk for example someone with
type 2 diabetes might be at risk of
high blood pressure and and then how
you'll be able to kind of
test that hypothesis across your entire
uh
population from now all the data has
been structured and linked
um amazon web services is helping solve
many of these challenges
and and the way we're trying to go
out is by providing the broadest and
deepest set of machine learning and ai
services for
for for your business so for example we
enable customers and and partners to
build secure
compliant and scalable solutions for the
delivery exchange of medical information
across the healthcare industry
or be able to kind of collate
information from the many other
underpinning systems
within a healthcare organization as i
mentioned
you know where your ekg data is or where
your medical imaging data or where your
medical record data
and then how you'll be able to securely
exchange that information and extract
the right level
of that information to create that
chronological view of every patient
and then apply the analytics at the
individual level or at the system level
which many healthcare organizations have
struggled to do
so far aws also provides technology and
tools needed to provide the
interoperability of these systems that
can streamline the structured
data exchange needed to improve
preventive and value-based care
by mapping to already known and
practiced clinical ontology whether from
the healthcare side or the billing side
or the operation side
and you'll be able to also adhere to
many compliance
across all these different
subsets we have also developed purpose
built ai services such as
amazon extract transcribe medical to go
after
transcription of medical conversation
amazon amazon comprehend medical to go
after
extracting analyzing medical information
and automating
workflows and surface insights trapped
in medical documents or text or
narratives
we also have machine
learning to the broadest set of uh
services in the cloud from pre-trained
ai services for computer vision
um language understanding uh as well as
recommendations and forecasting
um the amazon sagemaker
[Music]
is is our platform end-to-end service
that allows you to build
train and deploy machine learning models
at scale
um or be able to kind of build your own
custom model with support for all the
popular open source framework
uh such as tensorflow and pytorch and
mxnet if you have those skill sets
uh within your business uh the most
comprehensive cloud
to support your machine learning
workloads um
um that
comes really from providing all these um
frameworks or
end-to-end um platforms or this
um the specialized uh
apis that helps from
data storage security analytics compute
services
and and even more today we offer over
500 features and services of focus on
for example security and compliance
over 100 of those are hipaa eligible
services with certification for it
industry standards such as
iso and
among many others that can really help
with the global
customers as well we also
can we can accelerate adoption of
machine learning with uh with sagemaker
sagemaker as i mentioned is our managed
service that takes a number of the
required steps to build train and tune
and deploy machine learning
models and make it much easier for every
developer and scientist to use i mean
our goal is to make machine learning so
boring that anyone
with no prior knowledge machine learning
should be able to do
once you understand uh you know the kind
of question that you have
and what you want to go um about
answering that question where is the
data
and then the sagemaker can really help
you with the best in class
machine learning models are being
trained on on many different kind of
problems
then be able to kind of leverage that
within
a really easy to to build those models
and train them and before you can really
deploy them in your
in your system um it's been helping
organizations of all sizes to really
embrace machine learning
before machine learning before sagemaker
doing machine learning was
was just too hard for most customers
you need really if you didn't have a phd
machine learning or had
real a lot of depth in it there was no
way for
for for anyone to be able to do this at
scale and by making machine learning
easier and
low cost and secure many customers now
making better use of that the data they
already have
and um that is both valid and
differentiating
models that previously took customers
months for example
to an ex an extensive specialized
expertise
now they can build in in few days uh or
weeks
for instance if you look at how intuit
uh devalues machine learning models that
can pull
a year's worth of uh bank transactions
uh to find um deductible business
expenses for customers with uh sage
maker
was able to reduce development by time
by almost ninety percent and from six
months down to about a week
um amazon stage maker also lowers the
tco over three-year horizon by at least
54
compared to other cloud based machine
learning options
options such as self-self-managed amazon
ec2
or amazon managed elastic
kubernetes services um
the analysis uh hold true for small
teams
of five data scientists for example and
or extra
large teams with over hundreds of of
data scientists
um in addition to um to lower tco amazon
stage maker productivity
uh features enable you to put machine
learning ideas into
production faster and and then be able
to kind of improve data science
production by
up to 10 times in less than two years
since
um we've had the service over 10 000
customers have been adopting stage maker
across
pretty much every industry line and many
of them are making
their standards for building and
training and deploying their machine
learning algorithms
third to get the confidence of building
on aws
most comprehensive um
cloud platform optimized for machine
learning
is provided by aws that's why today if
you look at the amount of tensorflow for
example that runs in the cloud
about 85 percent of tensorflow in the
cloud runs on aws
we have a team that does nothing but
work on optimizing tensorflow
performance on aws so if you have those
skill sets
within your organization um that
require these kind of frameworks um such
as
tensorfro and and pytorch um
and they require a lot of innovation
we've we have that scaled and
and optimized on in aws
um and finally you need the right high
level of security that's reliable and
and fully featured data store with the
right access control
uh with a broader set of analytics and
really robust offerings so
at all these uh three layers of um
of aws um the offers from the frameworks
to the
uh managed platforms or the uh uh
specific
um uh apis um you'll be you'll have
a ton of capabilities that really can
for what needs what's needed to for
anyone
to be able to use these services
and to to build the next generation of
machine learning algorithms or
artificial intelligence applications
pre-trained ai services such as
amazon extract or comprehend medical and
transcribe medical
this is an area where if you look on top
of the the
the stack you'll be able to integrate ai
and machine learning capabilities
directly into
many of the healthcare workflows without
any machine learning expertise
basically for example um
briefly touch on also amazon kendra and
enterprise search and amazon
personalized for personalized
customer experience if i found if i
if i may i'll show you uh next how we're
able to
help many of these organizations with a
ton of um
of information trapped
in many of uh knowledge
[Music]
sort of repositories
such as clinical trials or such as
archival um
or or maybe many of the decision
support systems uh underpinning and
history of how
many decisions have been made so to be
able to have an enterprise search that
can really
uh sit on top of of although all this
information without
necessarily they they have and the depth
and expertise
in machine learning is is an area that
um that that's that's of high relevance
to many of our
uh customers we think about machine
learning as
really as a more of a like as i
mentioned of a micro level of
of having these different kind of layers
if you look at the bottom
layer we have the frameworks and
interfaces the
infrastructure for expert ml
practitioners
then at the framework layer there are
three
main frameworks that we support mainly
tensorflow
pytorch and also mxnet
very few ml practitioners um
use more than one framework today new
algorithms are being built
and developed all the times in different
frameworks that people want to be able
to
borrow from or run in that framework so
instead of having to port them
themselves to different frameworks we
provide we provide that service
for that and we have the dedicated teams
for each one of these these frameworks
as well i want to mention
or touch on one really key example
specific uh to the covet 19.
one of the greatest thing from knowledge
discovery
and data mining uh was um
something we haven't seen um uh in any
uh prior event i mean one of the
greatest things about this pandemic has
been
the shared volume of information being
shared by the scientific community and
research community
and practitioners worldwide every day
hundreds of these new articles are being
published in
pre-print servers pre-peer-reviewed
where the evidence is mounting and
everything is changing over time and
sometimes even conflicting with prior
understanding and that's a good thing
the challenge of course
for many researchers and scientists and
practitioners is be able to keep up uh
to keep up with with this shared volume
of information
so what we've done at amazon web
services is we
created a search website a new search
websites that powered
fully by machine learning that really
helped these researchers
uh and the public quickly and easily
search tens of thousands
of these research papers since the early
propagation of this
pandemic using national language
questions so court 19 uses
machine learning to services to power
comprehensive and actual results the
original data set
is enriched using amazon comprehend
medical so so that way we'll be able to
extract
all the medical terminology and
and the entities all the relationships
among these
and then from that then be able to uh
index
uh this information so that way uh we
can
create various topic modeling on top of
that such as
epidemio epidemiologic topic or vaccine
or laboratory or clinical trial
or population and then be able to help
the researcher
further navigate these topics in a most
comprehensive way
just by asking simple
questions to search this contact
context and content
so by extracting information from a
sexual text including for example
disease treatment and timeline
the data then become relevant for
example we can track the progression of
coping or be able to kind of interrogate
the data for
finding specific target or inhibitor
protein and then be able to kind of
further build a subset of articles that
might support or refute
the argument that you're going after
the court 19 search uses multi-label
classification model and inference
such as virology immunology or
laboratory clinical trials
then this information is indexed using
amazon kendra
which is a highly accurate enterprise
search service part of my machine
learning offered by
aws to deliver that robust
sort of national national language
query capabilities that make it really
easy uh to find the
rank related articles and then and these
articles that
in this corpus of data that's been sort
of made available by the allen institute
of artificial intelligence by working
with the
white house and many other industry
leaders out there
is open source some of this data goes
back about 20 years
of various viruses and including
different kind of covet sort of viruses
such as sars and
others and and various pandemics
throughout the last
20 years so so by finding relevant
information about this current pandemic
and then be able to relate
the evidence to other evidences from
other viruses or other
uh certain clinical trials or other um
pandemics along the way
uh is suddenly providing a really rich
experience for the researcher that they
don't have to necessarily
sift through um tens of thousands of
articles but also find the
right relevant material that's available
to them
that goes beyond just keyword extraction
and more into understanding the semantic
of this information the
topics that they're going after and the
meaning of this information in a really
uh um easy uh sort of national language
understanding uh query
um uh so so um and then be able then to
rank
this information based on relevance um
uh or best match
or even by decency or recency of uh
of that information uh the amazon
company in medical enriched data
and then the amazon kendra search
uh are built all from data available in
the public aws
kovit 19 data lake that's really
available to you and then we also made
this
solution available for any of you uh to
be able to go and and try to apply it to
different kind of
data that you might have whether it's
internally or or other public
data sets
today i mean i speak with healthcare
organizations a lot
on regular basis also like on on
um and and you can really see the
various journeys for each one of these
customers and and where they are
and their machine learning and analytics
experiences
um both of those that have probably
adopted machine learning throughout
their
organization as well as those that are
getting started
um through these conversations and our
own journey also at amazon over the
last 25 years or so corporate machine
learning
you know where we incorporate machine
learning almost every process that we
use
we've learned a lot of key things and
and the four main
key things that i share primarily with
these healthcare customers
is first you know
it is the data data is king and key
so machine learning must have the right
level high quality data
and the context there in order to
to start uh going after adopting
this next genera generation level of
machine learning
and while there's a lot being produced
companies today
and organizations struggle with how to
manage it
and how to extract the relevant meaning
from it and the context
second is organizational
uncertainty comes in the way often about
how to get started with machine learning
and where to apply it
to the business to have the most impact
third the the oftentimes there's the
skill gap
there aren't enough people today who can
build machine learning models
um and that's a really
um important
decision to be to be made when you're
trying to kind of go with this journey
this is why the way we built all our
services machine learning services
is to take many of that and
differentiate lifting
out of the equation so that way our
customers can really
have the right executive sponsorship and
championship
uh to build the machine learning culture
within their organization starting with
the data
starting with overcoming the
organizational and
uncertainty around the value of that
information
uh bridge those gaps in a skill set if
you have those machine learning skill
sets that's awesome if not
these services do not require any depth
in machine learning
other than understanding the value that
you're going after and why you need to
use these really awesome tools
um to get the right level of of support
what i always say to customers is don't
do the undeficient heavy lifting
and just focus on the outcome like you
know taking care of patients uh be able
to kind of
ensuring the highest quality
of care that can be delivered reduction
of operation efficiency
inefficiency in your organization as we
saw with the harvard with israel example
um about that you know how to optimize
the schedule and optimize the beds to
the
surgeon's schedules and how we can truly
take care of um
of a large population that's going
through your system and then be able to
efficiently have the best experience
for those patients and their caregivers
and and and ultimately the best uh
outcome and then the technology
companies do this for you
because we know how to do it at scale
with this i'd like to end there really
thank you so much for
for your time today and i look forward
to engaging further with you
um here's my twitter handle if you want
to
direct message message me or reach out
to me and i would love to
continue this dialogue and good luck to
you the rest of the
conference thank you so much